[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
new statesman's deputy online editor
rachel cunliffe and daily telegraph's
deputy political editor lucy fisher
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages
the metro points out that by the time
it's published there will be only seven
days to go until u.s president joe
biden's deadline to withdraw american
troops from afghanistan
the financial times looks ahead to
tuesday's g7 meeting suggesting
president biden will come under severe
pressure from key western allies
including the uk to extend that deadline
the eye has the headline u.s and britain
on collision course with the taliban
that race against time is also the top
story for the guardian
the telegraph hears that a person on the
uk's no-fly watch list made it onto a
military flight to birmingham but was
stopped before officially setting foot
on british soil and it's the same lead
story for the mail which also pictures
the twin girls who featured in our chief
correspondent stuart ramsey's report
this evening
and we're joined tonight by rachel
cunliffe and lucy fisher um let's turn
to the i first at lucy and we've got the
g7 summit coming up tomorrow boris
johnson and other european leaders to
put pressure on joe biden over this
august the 31st deadline
but the taliban says
no that's it
well that's right we've seen the
situation at kabul airport become
increasingly chaotic in recent days and
now the diplomatic tensions among the
western allies is becoming increasingly
fraught too as they exit
as you point out we've got this
emergency g7 call tomorrow at which we
expect the prime minister along with
emmanuel macron the french president to
really lead efforts to try and persuade
joe biden to remain in
kabul beyond the august 31st deadline
for finishing off the evacuation process
we know from all the mood music coming
out of washington that the americans
aren't keen at the moment on extending
that deadline even if there is agreement
an unexpected breakthrough tomorrow at
this g7 meeting then there's the issue
of facing negotiations with the taliban
so far sahel shaheen the spokesman has
said that it's a red line for the
taliban the end of this month and they
aren't minded to grant any extension
it's quite a humiliating position for
the west to be in that they could be
pleading with the taliban to extend this
and yet see that vetoed and and this
extension even just a couple of days
rachel
could mean thousands of lives being
saved
well definitely just in the last 24
hours the u.s were able to fly out 10
000 people so if you if you
look at that on a scale of a couple of
days of extension or even a couple of
hours of extension we are talking about
hundreds or even thousands of additional
lives being saved the issue as as lucy
says is it's not something for the west
to negotiate uh among themselves a lot
of the papers have the pressure on joe
biden and on the the u.s regime from
various western powers the british the
french the canadians and and others um
but even if the the u.s washington
decided to change its mind even if
anyone could change joe biden's mind the
prospect of the west led by the us going
cap enhance the taliban and say please
let us say a few extra days especially
when we've had this very strong pushback
from a taliban
spokesperson
i'm not sure any u.s administration
would want to take that risk of going
and asking for that extra time and then
being told no imagine the the optics of
that and imagine the optics of a new
taliban regime being able to say in our
first days uh in in power we were able
to push back the us in in in this way
and that's why i think that even though
the pressure is mounting the tensions
are very very very high uh and the idea
that we'll be able to get everyone out
to the british of the americans wants to
get out i think sadly it may not come to
pass
um lucy if we have a look at the
guardian i mean it has a photograph of
the very orderly lines as those who have
made it through uh line up to get onto
transporter planes
marked contrast to the scenes we've seen
out the airport but that warning that
was given by the taliban in an interview
with sally lockwood earlier today that
staying past the deadline would cross a
red line and provoke a reaction
um
it it does put the west in a very
difficult position ahead of that summit
boris johnson saying very strongly he
was going to push for this uh and
uh meanwhile outside thousands and
thousands of people continue to wait
well that's right it's uh you know after
20 years being in afghanistan um the uk
and the us can only at the moment hold
the perimeter of kabul airport and only
that at the consent of the taliban it's
been a fascinating spectacle to see um
british troops basically being watched
over by taliban officers crouching on
roofs from surveillance points around
the airport um mindsetting is uh from
whitehall sources the taliban you know
have been helpful on the ground for
example and splitting up the cues of
people looking to leave via us routes
and via uk routes into different gates
of course that does contrast with some
of the appalling reports we've heard uh
coming from the ground from sky news and
others about um afghans waiting outside
the perimeter fence being crushed um
facing beatings um lashings um from from
taliban uh officials and waiting there
so it is a very very fraught situation
um as as rachel said you know we're
seeing lots of people up to thousands
per day being evacuated in the past 24
hours the us have got out 10 000 people
the uk another valiant effort another
1800 um but there are still many many
people left and of course if we are only
there another seven days before that
august the 31st deadline then it will be
the case um as we've seen ben wallace
say choked with emotion that sadly some
people many people possibly will be left
behind
at the front of the telegraph
lucy's byline there at rachel on
the news that one security suspect
managed to get to the uk from kabul
well i'll let lucy do more on this than
i will given that it's her story uh but
one of the things that struck me reading
this is just the chaos the chaotic
scenes that we are seeing uh at the
airport the footage that we're getting
the stories that we're getting as well
are very very brave uk officials who are
trying to process applications and visas
and passports as quickly as they
possibly can with an absolute skeleton
staff the sheer numbers of people who
are desperately trying to to catch a lot
a flight out some of whom may not have
all their documents in order because why
would you if you if you fled with next
to nothing and as a result of all that
chaos and all of that pressure i think
it is sadly
inevitable that there will be people
trying to get through who perhaps
shouldn't be uh certainly these were
four five individuals on the no-fly list
who attempted to to get through four of
them were stopped one of them made it
onto the plane
and i just think it speaks to the the
pressure that officials are under and
also sadly that if various western
countries are staging this mass
evacuation effort which is what they're
doing of course there are going to be
people who take advantage of that either
for their own personal reasons because
they're desperate
or in a more sinister way because they
wish to do harm to the countries that
they are seeking asylum yeah lucy give
us a bit more detail then about what
happened in this particular case
yes well this was a story um that was
broken by uh sky news's sam coats
earlier today
a briefing for mps from solari bristow
the uk ambassador in kabul at the moment
helping those emergency efforts to
process visas for afghans fleeing um
told mps uh today that uh someone won a
suspect on the uk's no-fly list um had
made it on board a flight
the uk board of force authorities were
alerted overnight the individual has
been arrested
in birmingham but it will raise further
questions about the security
implications of the uk's plans to
take in 20 000 refugees from afghanistan
over the next five years
i think we've seen so many you know
often young soldiers let alone trained
consular staff on the ground in kabul
trying to carry out this really
important work under such tough
difficult circumstances they are to be
applauded for what they're doing but
it's interesting there's
questions tonight about how much support
they're getting from um the foreign
office i spoke to tobias elwood the tory
chairman of the commons defense select
committee he said that the uk had
secured um the airport site and its
evacuation plan agreed that with the
taliban border force staff should have
been sent out there to really help this
process through um as it is uh you know
officials are insisting that
the person caught coming into the uk
shows that the databases
are working that the process is in place
um to catch these people that shouldn't
be allowed into the country um are um
are are working well but i still think
that there are questions to be answered
about about the the processes on the
ground and how it's going to work going
forward particularly in this last
scramble in the days coming up yeah and
the latest update on that is that the
home office has confirmed that upon
further investigation this individual is
no longer a person of interest to the
security agencies or law enforcement it
does raise questions about as you say
how they could have got on the flight
but also
others who are on a no-fly list in kabul
still who may not need to be
now um let's just turn to the mail
which has very emotive images on its
front page it has twin girls who
featured in
stuart ramsey's report who have made it
uh through and are on a flight back to
britain
alongside that the images of a brother
and sister that was seen by an itv news
team i believe who it is understood have
been left behind after their parents
managed to get through in the scramble i
mean it is
devastating the scenes that we are
seeing out there we've seen missing
children posters we've seen babies being
handed over barbed wire this is a
humanitarian crisis rachel on an
unprecedented scale
yes and i think it's the it's it's the
children aspect obviously that is
incredibly emotive as it always is but
those images as well of as you said
children being passed over fences
similar to uh the the images of the the
helicopter out of saigon and and
parents lifting up their their infant
children in the hope that they could
they could get away also seeing reports
we've seen reports the last few days of
people being uh shot and and sadly dying
at the airport in that mad crush uh
people trying to get through
and reports of people being told even if
they do have uh
a visa or a passport they are meant to
be on one of those flights being told
not even to attempt to go to the airport
because of the chaos there so even
though in a previous the previous paper
we saw the the order or the semblance of
order that
we shouldn't forget that this is an
incredibly
chaotic semi-war zone or about to become
a war zone and one of the lines in the
mail story just struck me which is that
the the uk is trying to get out 6 000
people before the deadline at the end of
the month really
the number they'd want to get out is
seven thousand so that's a thousand
people at least whom uk officials think
should be in this country and deserve to
be in this country and would like to get
out but they just know won't be able to
and that's
that's a thousand people that is that is
a lot of people who were unable to save
because of the timing of this retreat in
the way it's all been handled
um rachel lucy we're going to take a
brief pause coming up after the break
the school summer holidays are nearly
over but is covered under enough control
to ensure children's safe return we'll
be discussing that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now rachel kunliff and
lucy fisher we're going to return to the
front of the guardian now uh rachel
um for its coverage on coronavirus
pandemic and the prospect of schools
returning
yes so the school's going back in uh
just over a week and the oh is it two
weeks
soon soon school's going back soon uh
and the death rate is at a hundred of a
seven day average which is kind of the
highest it's been all summer and
obviously the hope during summer was
that the vaccine rollout would mean that
even though cases might go up
hospitalizations and deaths wouldn't and
they're still only at a tenth of where
they were during the winter peak but
still deaths are creeping up to such an
extent that there are concerns about
schools going back and the
increased transmission when that
happened now the rules changed over the
summer which meant that double-backed
adults and children crucially children
whether they had vaccinations or not
would no longer have to self-isolate if
they came into contact with a positive
case which was meant to enable schools
to go back and open
in person without the the mass absences
and the pandemic that we saw in the in
the last few weeks of the summer term
when we had hundreds of thousands of
school children who who weren't actually
attending this is the guardian raising
the first warning signs that maybe the
return to school may not be quite as
smooth as parents and teachers and
government officials are hoping which
just fills me with terror partly as
someone who will have to handle it if
school's close again but also because
the amount of disrupted learning that
our children have undergone over the
last 18 months how much they've missed
out on particularly the poorest and the
most disadvantaged students who haven't
been able to learn online i think it's
an absolute national scandal and the
fact that we're getting to
just weeks before term time realizing
that there might be certain amount of
disruption yet again
uh just the the lack of planning in the
education department i think is is
atrociously something that we should all
be worrying about yeah i share your
fears there was a real hope wasn't there
that for for all our children's sakes
that they could return to some degree of
normality uh in september let's uh see
um lucy to the metro now uh anti-vaxxers
storming itn's building
yeah uh this isn't the first time we've
seen um anti-vaxx protesters um making a
stand at a broadcaster we had a similar
episode only a matter of weeks ago
when another bbc studio was stormed
today jon snow
73 year old broadcaster was was led by
past the protesters by security
who attacked him shouting at him about
uh about his coverage of the pandemic
other demonstrators were heard to shout
for robert peston um i just think you
know
peaceful protest um i'm all for and is a
right that must be defended but the
increase we're seeing in people coming
to buildings coming to people's place of
employment in a bid frankly to
intimidate them is unacceptable yeah an
itn saying that their journalists have
been prevented from doing their jobs as
a result and let's just have one quick
look uh at the telegraph uh a story on
the front right at the bottom there
rachel before we go about a tortoise
hunting and killing a chick
so this is actually i love a good animal
story even though this is sadly a chick
has been eaten by a tortoise but it's so
cool uh not for the chick obviously but
this is the first uh evidence of a
tortoise killing and eating a live
animal so this is new information that
we're learning about talk system it's
got this lovely last line at the end
where it says the lack of speed and
dexterity mean they are still sadly one
of the least efficient predators on the
planet which i think is a bit harsh
given that this tortoise has just made
history
by eating this bird um
yeah i love a good animal story even if
it involves dead baby animals and i
think tortoises are really really cool
and i used to desperately want one as a
pet although now having read this i
think possibly they're a bit aggressive
for me